today we're trying on sexy edibles
I like sex and I like eating this if
your mouth is gonna be on a dick or in a
vagina in a butt then what's wrong with
Kansas sex is sticky enough as is let's
get to strip it and get to lickin I'm
ready I'm hard let's go bring forth the
candy candy band for men Oh Katie God no
it's okay I got it this is a square it's
like a fruit roll-up proof by the six
inches yes hold on baby let me put on my
edible pants this isn't candy
these aren't pants this looks like a
used maxi pad no I think I get it though
it's got these little ties we're just
kind of cute hold on honey I broke it
doesn't make my butt look good does that
work is that sexy I feel pretty good
about the way it makes my body look but
apparently I can eat it I'm going
straight for the dick my dick is
bleeding oh that's like sour doesn't age
like a food by a foot does taste like
pants oh that's not the flavor I was
expecting Oh clears we gonna vomit do
you think my saliva is right now yeah so
bad oh they're like stuck to my teeth
oh good eat any more of this Jamie oh oh
god they're turning my hands read and
write
[Music]
I'm pooping a grocery bag and all my
teeth and this is supposed to be mixed
with semen and butt and vagina juice
yeah so if somebody's big like this
monster this is where we're starting for
remember when it was in my butt
lovers candy brawl and lovers candy
g-string
oh it's like a puka shell necklace for
your ass no normal strings don't feel
great up but oh that is a new feeling
we're gonna think that this would defuse
my farts and they would just smell like
roses
I feel like I'm pulling this off I might
text a picture to my wife just pretend
I'm a girl everybody pretend to have a
girl I feel like this is a good thing to
try on Valentine's Day if you want to
look cute and sexy look at it's like a
little abacus at 6 once twice where do
you eat first on this we should get
something to eat this off of me I didn't
want to have my wife be subjected to
having to eat this on camera
[Laughter]
[Applause]
how do we know are you wearing edible
lingerie right now maybe unwrap your
present what do you think now so yeah so
but do you think I look cute
no it goes up your butt I don't even
have a cute ass like that so you just
break it off no no no no you bite it off
what's there safer faster I feel like a
guy's just get to the point we're like
wham bam sit on to the right stick it in
do it where should I go first
alright so now I'm gonna you up boy
lay down babe this is for every
fifteen-year-old girl for comments on
the try guys videos here's a dick one oh
my god eggs like bite on my face I can't
get the horn it just you okay it's like
salty and sweet so we decided we'd send
eugene out of the room and have them
play a little game called which white
guy is a tasting we won't reveal the
answers until you've done oh okay but
I'm least looking for does act because I
just don't know where there would be no
hey I have a honey dust powder which
smells like baby powder and
potpourri
I already smell the
there that was baby powder on the white
guy was Ned
it tasted like babies I've got some
spearmint sensation body gel which is
good Oh nightmare on my body
[Applause]
why are you give me hair flavored stuff
sack
it had to be Zach because there was a
lot of hair that was like flossing I
have a tropical flavored body paint real
steamy cover photo here better not be on
someone's an ass or balls okay okay
that was probably the best tasting punch
go ahead change my answers that was one
of the softest things
[Applause]
[Music]
that was one of the most terrifying
experiences of my life but I'm glad I
did it with you guys yeah well I learned
today whatever goes down between two
consenting adults totally fine I'm gonna
eat anywhere else I don't really want to
eat anywhere else what's the point it is
nothing tasted good not just because it
was on our dish highly arousing well if
you wanted to spice things up I could
see that'd be fun maybe I want to be mad
laughs now that's shaving cream I think
this experience only brought us closer